it's the tenkan World Tour Finals 20 of
the best players in the world will be
battling for the title
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at closing out with the perfect the
culmination of the technical world tour
who do you guys think is going to take
the time for some Tekken 7 make some
noise
[Music]
you're finally here the Second World War
World Finals here from Bangkok Thailand
my name is Mark man I'm here with spag
the guy in guys how's it going man I'm
excited mark man I'm excited extremely
excited this is what we've been fighting
for the entire year we're finally here
the very end who will be our new
champion an amazing day yesterday with
the LCQ like we did last year but this
year Tekken has excelled time and time
again man we have the most diverse group
of players here to compete today we've
ever had before walk now I want to talk
about this all day but instead I want to
see how this is all going to go down so
without further ado let's get our
qualified players up here and find out
where they're gonna be playing in the
pools yes but we want to just say that
we're gonna be starting with number four
on the on the leaderboard going down
there is a nice make sure you stay tuned
pay attention this is gonna be how the
battle plays out so I hope you guys are
ready for it let's go ahead and call our
first player up on the stage from South
Korea that we have Jay DCR oh man JDC aw
man it's good to see you bro how have
you been preparing for this my life I've
not really seen you much recently but
you were doing really really value in
America a lot this year so how have you
been preparing for this tournament today
a lot easier
I like last year I think and I was
before I got your tile and I wasn't you
know I wasn't like too much but I see
I'm here and I didn't say that everybody
able to play from all all over the world
and then I feel like what's more
motivating and you know I just want to
play play well have a look at the pools
behind you and choose where you want to
go who do you want to go against yeah I
just got cheese back
see see he is in Group C guys JDC off
thank you so much dude good luck for
today oh man Pool C is looking stacked
already ha
alright we're gonna go ahead and get our
next competitor up from Japan we have
Chikara which occur in Shakuni Chiklis
on genki deska
game kit is nice that's all the Japanese
I know have take a look over here which
would you would you like to be in have a
choice C D si si si whoa ladies just wow
good luck put today good luck good luck
he was going right belter JD's yard I
did not expect this I thought he was
gonna go for a B or D you know is a
weird one but wow he chose JD CI you
must have a plan alright so we have a
new player here in the World Finals he
wasn't here last year but he has
definitely made some waves oh yeah I'm
Pakistan we have our sling ash all about
the man of the year other still on how
are you doing my bro
fine how are you all good all good look
this year has been so crazy for you dude
oh this yeah I prepare hard for this
because I lost like Nasser to run
errands but inside you're in a good
position right now a salon take a look
behind you which group would you like to
be in are you gonna go and see as well
let's go in
hey hey quick that was a quick decision
a 4-hour salon I feel like he doesn't
get he doesn't catch hey alright so our
next player from South Korea we have
coca ma come on and younger say oh he's
all smiles how are you doing would you
get much no didn't get much sleep
yeah okay okay yeah where would you like
to go here take a look take a very take
hard think hard last year you were in
Group D I remember that one yeah I just
be be all right he's gonna let fate
decide
another empty group so yeah smart I
think smart Nick yes so we're gonna go
ahead get our next player by way of
France we have super cool
[Music]
come over here Winnie talk to me how are
you feeling here Vinny you're the only
representative of Europe this year how
does it feel being the only
representative of your continent
stressful haha a man of very few words
take a look behind you Vinny what are
you gonna go in okay so B C or D pick
one D B okay okay
B so he's gonna be with coma yeah I mean
he had the opportunity go with D and let
fate decide but I guess you wanted
control some of his matchup yeah exactly
so up next another new player on the twt
we have again from Pakistan we have a
wise honey
[Applause]
you got a GG boy representing a
salam-o-alaikum bike and co-op no are
you confident yes I will it behind you
by which group okay D alright good so a
waste is gonna be in another empty group
there awaits the first person in Group D
probably be change up a lot of things I
don't know a lot of players want to go
battle against them this early on at
least in the pool stage but let's go
ahead and get our next player up here
all the way from South Korea we have
full Sun beside I'm gonna say oh how are
you doing I'm good how do you feel about
today's tour nevermind like yo your
season has been very good you know a lot
of ups and downs how are you feeling
today I'm good um I'm ready to enjoy a
final do you think you're prepared yeah
good good have a look here Oh son we
have names in every group now which one
takes your fancy can I just
we should remind everyone what it fills
out to four people that group is locked
okay all right group came up with our
structure he is the first one to
challenge arson - that's gonna be an
interesting one
all right from Japan our next player we
have double-double Ohio are you doing I
lost weight you know we're Japanese but
last year you you know you and LCQ you
didn't win this time you're in the world
- how do you feel good yes I want be B
or B is almost closed up okay couple
with Kakuma
and super Akuma so you have a Korean a
European and a Japanese very diverse
group them on all right yeah there's
very diverse so we're gonna go
switchback we have from South Korea we
have from South Korea chanel rocks
talking Chanel massive personality happy
birthday oh my god is his birthday guys
[Applause]
Chanel how are you doing good good get
you want to choose your group a choice
hard choice I remembered to buy last and
on
no maybe D D guys chanel has gotta waste
honey in his recipes ready
so yes it's gonna be always Sonia and
Chanel in Group D so it's looking very
good we got to well we've got these
groups are pinning up mark yeah
last year's champion is actually coming
up on stage right now we have from Japan
I'm sorry he's been there alive he's
living in Japan there he's living that
out from South Korea no don't run rob to
last year's champion everybody see I
don't know if the speak Japanese seem
real in Japan all the time I saw him
there like last week I speak English
thank you how are you doing good the
last year's like water champion do you
think you can do it again this year
I tried good what wow wow groups I miss
group see guys he would just he just
made it up straight away all right the
decision was made straight away Group C
with JDC articulate and now it's wrapped
you in the mix as well all right our
next player coming probably has maybe
the furthest trip all the way out here
all the way from Peru no salt
latin-american player here we have a
bail deal a straw hola hola hola como
estas we're getting the air Mugen are
you doing how do you feel today feel
confident that you can win this
tournament good good
have a look over here my brother which
group do you want to be in
getting hard now guys getting hard feel
like he is the B group right that one's
spending a pasamonte so B is actually
closed out for any new players that
we're pulling up right now right yes
that's it that's it that's done all
right so let's go ahead and get our next
player up here all the way from the
United States we have Jimmy J Tran Oh
[Applause]
Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy how you doing my
brother of course I mean you're always
so calm as usual you know you've been on
the stage before how do you do do you
think you can bring it home I got one
chance okay okay
have a look at this way have you been
you've have you've got a chance not to
see how its unfolding which takes your
fancy a B C Group D aways honey and
Chanel and Jimmy J Tran the first
American up on stage will be all right
Dean that's exciting
up next coming from Japan
we have no be a legend we are you doing
which group do you want to be in nobody
sorry D oh my gosh group is looking good
at the group is looking stacked very
stacked and of course that closes out
that group as well yes until later wow
that was quite the surprise so our next
player coming up also from Japan that we
have no Roma Rahman
this is getting crazy these are not the
pigs in the pools that I expected it's
crazy man
well not many choices left the robot
look people have been avoiding that
group on the road moments straight there
you could have gone to see but no he's
gone for a arsalan us on an aroma
interesting interesting so now we have
another first time here from the United
States we have shadow 20z shadow man
you've had an amazing season this time
man this year how you got much choice
left it's either gonna be good a group
see which one takes your fancy here hey
hey you want
alright so shadow is locking on a wow we
have some crazy pools here Korea America
Pakistan in Japan Wow
so not like there's much of any choice
here we're gonna go ahead and call up
our last qualifier here we have from
Korea st. wow that sets up quite the
battle in this potential final pool see
you don't have a much of a choice here
but we want you to pick who where are
you gonna be going and other Saints it's
a very hard decision where would you
like to only see I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay Group C was safe there was a
formality we have to do it yeah so we
have four players left this is a new
twist we have with the rules this year
it's changing quite a bit so our top
ranked player on the two on the points
list list is knee and now knee is gonna
pick where he wants to go so let's get
our number one ranked player on the
Tekken world tour knee to the stage need
from South Korea
he's been traveling and playing a lot of
Technology he's been grinding me my
friend you have been all around the
world practicing practicing practicing
you went to Pakistan recently how are
you feeling today are you ready I want
to play or lady you already want to play
he's anxious to play so I have a look
you have the choice with your number one
of the leaderboard which group do you
want to be you can now see all the
players this is gross because you
remember only two players of each pool
are gonna make it out it's our top mate
he's got history with all my [ __ ]
shoes arsalan oh my god
that is gonna be quite the pool but men
knee is locked in let's go in and bring
up our number-two ranked player on the
second world tour from the United States
we have an again you how about an
amazing season to some mannequin you
have levelled up so much from last year
how are you preparing for this how'd you
feel just wanted to make sure that I
could be as relaxed and as comfortable
as possible going into this tournament
it's kind of been the mentality that
I've had all year making sure that uh I
prepare really well for tournaments just
outside of playing the game a lot and
with that said I'd like to enter grafite
bootp and it get lakhs in a group be the
strategic placement here from our second
ranked player all right we're gonna go
ahead and get ranked number three on the
twt leaderboard from south korea we have
low hi oh hi he's not quite a year as
well
how you doing man how you feel oh I I
want
I believe my or p-character yeah I lost
to this guy to time Wow look at that no
hi I'm not taking the easy route he said
I've rested this guy before I'm going to
Group D that leaves our LCQ winner below
coming up on the stage from Pakistan
where again he's not gonna have much
choice here but he's gonna confirm with
us who he's gonna be playing against by
Jessie uh how are you doing bro I'm fine
oh you all good like you did so well
yesterday man you said you to me earlier
that you didn't expect to actually win
the LCQ but you're in form right now how
do you feel I'm feeling ready because of
yesterday I didn't expect that I will
win so now I am confident so have a look
at that is what much choice you gonna be
in Group C I think they don't know
already starting the mental warfare I
like it nice what the Gustav Bilal is
gonna be in group that's the last guy
there the LC cute and all groups are set
do you think he really wanted that group
I think so all right well it worked out
for him the one the LCQ and now got the
group that he wanted but guys we are
about to get started with the matches
we're going straight into the action are
you ready I don't know man I don't know
you have to be I hope so man yes let's
go guys make some noise here for the
second World Tour Finals 2019 we're
gonna throw it back to our commentary
desk and get started with the match to
see you guys in a bit
Tekken World Tour 2019 and we are here
in Bangkok Thailand for this finals and
man majin Obama coming at you with mr.
level up your game and somehow you feel
a rip feeling fantastic those groups are
ridiculous
oh my gosh we've got to get things
started a group a the ones we can we
start off with our sling ass picking the
a group here for the a our students go
there
I mean I'm warm I'm more about me
picking a group oh we're gonna get a
seat go [ __ ] of course
down a fax them but here's the whole
group Arthur Nash Olson neuroma shadow
20z and knee that's gonna be group a I
mean just look at this whole we're over
although right then but--my you've got
cocoon with super Akuma double a belt on
micro actor probably the hardest group
to predict here right it's like the most
wildcards I think and then you go over
to see but I'll just says they don't
know Akuma
JDC are in st. echo fox boys now rivals
chicken and ranked you also in that
group and then finally Group D is a
bloodbath
you got a wise honey Chanel Jimmy J can
no be and low I I feel like Jimmy and
know we're always in these things
together this group is ridiculous hide
by fate man and the cool thing is 880
pools to write five different countries
five difficulys that the national
representation in the each group is oh
man you're gonna get so you this is
about to turn into a bloodbath man I'm
excited
and of course guys the way this works is
they're round robins or each of these
groups the top two players out of each
one will move on to the top eight so
three of these guys are not making it
out of each of these groups that is
daunting thing about looking at some of
these players you got in the first day
yeah coming up get ready for it run mmm
yoni is gonna be coming up to the stage
for our first match he's gonna be going
up against USA's shadow 20z this is
gonna be crazy I think shadow definitely
one of the most overlooked players in
this top twenty you know I think that
he's got a great shot here he's been
training all year long he's been travel
traveling to many many events you know
he managed brother junior as well thinks
of disrupt gaming but this is the
tallest order you got to get right he
got me up there it's the morning right
now but me picking this pool with arson
- it's gonna be crazy it feels like -
with shadow right he's really kind of I
mean just the way it feels man he's
coming to his own really in the past
couple years right two years he's had
huge improvement he's one of the more
well travel USA players I would also say
as well but going up against tech in
itself man this is knee Korea versus USA
here group-stage
yeah this is huge oh man what characters
chatted me obviously we've seen a lot of
his claw do we know he's also got a
Safina back there me he uses everything
yeah but what's gonna be Brian is that
we're gonna see you know my my you up my
fanfic that was writing earlier this
year's like he can't beat Arthur than
tournament but what if at the end of the
finals he does it with Brian you know he
has to bring back his man it's only we
can get it done in tournament I mean
obviously we can do it along sit but
maybe in tournament who knows yeah going
back to Bay and in this kind of
situation would be that would be
something really but the other thing to
man is like I feel like it's catch-22 to
on it I feel like there's more pressure
on Ashe at this point to now the whole
world why huh though in a way that no
one was before right what people were
actively looking to write you off before
at this point now it's like you won both
knee bows you come into this Tekken
World Tour final it almost feels like
it's a catch-22 if you don't win this
people are gonna be talking about if you
either way either way use the amount if
you sliced wheat recently but he had
some tweet about a life you know when
the Eagles are quiet the parents are you
know definitely feel like pair right try
get some Froot Loops yeah let's go
neighbors shadow right here oh man
how are we gonna open up this tech and
Walt or 2019 finals yeah it's gonna be
good oh the Brian fury all right back to
bay da Bay in the arena perfect and what
interactions are you looking at
with these two characters for people at
home watching right for they know about
the big long-range counter hit threats
from Brian but then of course you also
have genocide cutter and then those
installs at the starburst mode from
Claudio as well o or that's you start
off a close-range counter hit right
there you gonna take it to the wall in
bang and the wall pressure so scary
yeah of course you know anytime you get
to Brian fury can't the wall nice low
Barry you gotta watch out for those tech
balls where you can't fall the techel's
you really got to mix up your timing and
getting up off with the ground dance a
back and forth between both players
right knee on the ground and then you
want all you want OCA's any as well yes
of course the best strategy is to not
get knocked down but you know good luck
with that spending even the open seats
of shadow though very great to the
pokies opponent using the back three the
new it new attack from Claudio you can
see it a lot probably later but
not taking the time feeling out knee
dropping that shoulder back one of them
tagging him lo look at him just standing
there chill yo he is done is all making
shouting he is solid I mean everyone
makes fun of me no you doesn't have an
expressed he's expressionless right but
that's what it's like that's what it
takes in this kind of a turn informant
time winding down eight seconds shadow
with the lead here raise for me and
there you go shadow get in the first
round get you talking about his lack of
expression dude it's bogus for him
mm-hmm you come out here to Thailand you
able to qualify this year like that
especially the way you did a homeboy
gosh Superman punch a close-range tackle
reversal get off a jock yeah but he
didn't get the launch off it and right
now shadows look great genocide
underneath all the counter it and
shadows gonna take a quick chill out
lead over knee here three all right
let's see what he's got though a lot of
people Tama how like shadows by the most
overlooked player here like he has the
most potential of a get that top it's
naked that had to be enacted me shaking
his head immediately right after I had
to get some big positioning big damage
here - 50% up at the wall again subtle
side step left a weave his way out get
parallel and shadow recognize the cycle
immediately goes the homing attack and
look at the three Oni here in the first
if you can close it out but Nia's great
positioning right now she has got to be
careful the knockdown guarantee down
back three last pics with this game and
hatchet for me
when he's dry spend up the night a
minute the down for solid stuff shadow
taking it three rounds straight over
nears had a really good movement
especially in input in frame advantage
situations for knee you saw him he
didn't really panic will you just hold
his guard or move out of the way created
a whip on his opportunity at the end of
the last round you know it doesn't
matter who he's going up against you
know he's unfazed that's the power of
shadow that's how he's been playing so
long - but you still so young doesn't
have that fear of failure and that's
very true very true but right now
keeping the pressure up they're trying
to keep them much close to the time nice
jab inter up and they're coming to back
these out of shadow doesn't work that
way
no yeah because we sold over to scramble
and he cat the back one counter here
comes the hatchet for one test
Oh got a squid finish at the end shadow
keeping the little nod they're like all
right I feel like this all because that
one scramble situations a shadow you
he's gonna recompose hear me though he's
starting to put it together here's a low
parry it's like yo that was just the
first game of the day males my warmup
and that these knees at the wall hatch
it set the offset for shadow making the
throne
jab check from each player and I'm both
at work and I look at the channel four
in a row the back and forth of it too
right when he started to find his temple
that's what shadow turns it up in that
mid-range challenge it he's got raids
though super metal o'clock rage before
now got me here but there's the rage
back from Brian shadow still has this to
go not gonna pull the trigger there
Brian's got that much but you gotta be
careful he knows about it ready for this
little boy standing up for both players
ooh
break up the ground Oh finish it then
able to get them looking down for old
man me answering back right now getting
the first two rounds your game to catch
it
maahox denied and will off with his back
he's come after us back nice block with
needle stuff he's hatchets adding up
back one pushing shadow towards the wall
what the whole disposition fine him a
spy mission court shadows guard not
breaking though patience from both of
them Oh shadows bill in this blocks the
raise up yet time winding down here
shadows a little bit behind I think oh
he's got the lead now oh bring it back
three rounds crate of his own to tie it
up Ike you got to give props to shadow
man his patience and some of those
scenarios with this back to the wall he
was not it he was perfectly cool to just
hold his guard not even try to get too
overzealous with movement even he's
really just cool I'm gonna take this
pressure wait for the opening yeah he
didn't really good there of course and
you know as that set went on I feel like
the first round that little scramble
situation happened he was caught off
guard pulled it back together I think
about the third round he I start playing
like the first game again so here we go
this final game she was pretty
interesting violent systems the states
that shadow has selected here should be
a good one
there's a lot of back and forth between
these two players especially lanes your
arrangement one really just playing
around the each other each characters
jabs like that
yeah shadow he went so handsome jab like
me check twice like man but it's like I
got jabs to yeah and then of course the
third of the vizac up close right
mmm-hmm counter hit launches and that's
thing he's been set up with back through
this entire set so you know the second
it's coming exactly it's a counter a
launcher and it's delay about
oh speaking of last-hit people watching
strings meet to the wall here not quite
long and there was you know you pull the
trigger on that technique patient now
the - pressures starting to come out a
little bit more from me
confident this channel was just sit
setting up endure the cross gonna
counter at the time this time sighs just
short the wall again and you left shadow
and rage with algebraic drop from me
there and these not confirm very well
right now then rate dives gonna connect
I don't know this give me close oh it's
just short Oh shadow closed out goes
with the min to fight off the bat touch
your toes
Superman punch building up the plus ring
me all too ready with these throw braces
hey yeah it's magic name you don't see
the three every time to the walls
prevent punch install star first active
and now shadow with the wall pressure
slows adding up
nice weekend for his life good awesome
these Jan stuff a little bit too scared
to pull the trigger he is in some
trouble right now gonna have to hold us
raise your back one good patience here
for me
you know the hatchets are gonna come but
scary because he's got that rage drive
ready to go behind it again hold that
space 3 + 4
you called it first hatchet so far what
a good and there's a rager I spend now
10 second shadow with the leap trying to
close it out here 504 me two seconds
shadow when he got in last chance
nothing down poor Jimmy close that I was
one second on the clock we're tied up
the dance and then he gets the one foot
through grab first throw the set oh boy
and then Ponsonby set each other
multiple times throughout the set for
this final game of both them are not
fair faltering at all
with a really good mixer just chat
pressure in low post builds up this life
lead hatchet mm-hmm and he is so patient
gets that back room in that shadow again
Duncan find the range of drop in the
combo stops back to sidestep but again I
like the back room kick attempt shadows
got a pixel oh my goodness then is now
at that point for need kids and the
Fishman let's go chat flow oh my god and
you know we're going to the wall huh
that what you got for maybe eight he's
feeling good now knees on fire right now
rate will foreshadow last chance
punishes this that's a start always
definitely fill it up it's a star trip
yo shadow can you get it done poof and
go all the jab from me me get it get it
done here get the W over shout a two to
one no one sec man that was a great way
to start off the day and you got to
remember with the egg group states to
even that's who one is important because
it ever comes down to game differentials
and tiebreakers in some scenarios as as
we want to know then we know very well
from last year exactly I've me ends up
to owing everyone else and Chavez got a
lead
you know that's persisting how that's
gonna go so that one game that shadow
got initially there that's huge for
that's huge that back and forth in range
one rain zero like that again just
playing around the jabs and low folks if
it felt like yet shadow very few very
few genocide genocide cutter attempts at
all the one butoxide he did try you got
floated very early on
we're just denied well punished I
thought it was very smart up that you
see the update on the screen there but
need get in that victory over shadow
here and yeah you know they were setting
each other from the very first game like
you saw shadow wasn't use it back in
second team starts using back you but
not finishing the X days finish to me is
like I understand which kind of you here
I'm not gonna then finally know he was
going hatchet every time but he never
went for the mid until the final game
like final round even I think really
really tedious back especially like
between those two players so many rounds
going to the last seconds like that oh
yeah they were so patient yeah you know
shadow of course you know stepping up
against me they're not easy to do for
anyone but obviously unfazed this is why
using the top twenties and wise you're
at the finals yeah for sure
coming up next though we've got red
oles Arslan ash that's why the same man
by the way that Red Bulls Arslan ash
going up against Ulsan and all songs was
a pleasure had a crazy year to write
we saw him way back in BAM Melbourne
Australia because that's where I was a
crazy unbelievable set and that's really
I've really put him out ahead early on
right him we get you know cash and 300
points on a master event early on like
that and ever since then he hasn't had
the same really like strong performances
but he's been able just again accumulate
points accumulate points right it's as
soon as you have that one masters event
win on your on your on your list it's
really just about the accumulating
points of staying in the mix up until
then and all something's able to do that
but he hasn't worn in a while he needs
to eat you have to imagine especially if
you go in this group up against MRSA man
who everybody has their eyes on and
especially with the type of player all
the Sun is you know he's from watching
film you know he was watching all those
sets last week but he chose this right
don't get you he was the first person
pick himself into the arson ash group he
had other choices he's like that's the
one I want I want arsonist the match he
gets first and that's that's what I love
about this format - I like what people
call each other out or you see people
duck you see people duck like that I
don't let me get some of that you know
or whatever but man old side you know
like we mentioned it might be his time
right now you know he's as you mentioned
you he has been a little lackluster in
the second half of the year but you know
he's always gonna be a contending
faculty chose this here crazy and don't
forget arson ashes characters you know
they all gotta likes minor reduction and
minor nerves going into the season but
now oh God
going with Bob here again Heartland axis
kazumi Bob in the finals I didn't expect
that and for hash to write you were
mentioning again that character
selection it feels like the cause of me
in recent months has kind of been sealed
low key right he has to play there's so
much in tournament events but look
around here and she's feel great right I
mean I mentioned the nurse a second ago
but injecting when Karen's getting RIF
they're rarely are ever actually get you
know they're always gonna be by of
especially with her tool kit right she's
a fundamental technique Eric she has
really good generic tools and then just
obviously high damage output at the wall
as well even that magical from Arthur
Nash and I'm thinking maybe the Bob pick
here is actually because it didn't want
to run the mirror match the high gap
rats let's see how it goes watch cats
fight and the chat float and return
arson ash takes the first round nice and
solid rim is where it's gonna get dicey
man chopped up knees in your chest I'm
gonna take you on the wall your arse
look came to play he's ready to go put
this tiger on you like the rest stick
hmm can't decide stepping in the
downpour one pressure this is what is
his pressure with jabs down for ones and
of course Rolling Thunder boy I mean
that that's the fundamental technical us
to move and add it on top awesome that
quick two rounds here against old sod
and normally we're so impressed with
where he stands his spacing and his
reactions but right now he's just
walking on something he's so comfortable
it's like in this match
lobster kick you don't really see a
whole lot especially not a tekken 7 but
right now you know i said like yeah we
play them all the time Wow just out of
range and then just rolling thunder whip
punished
and I love the - block of Arslan - yes
so active nets looks so fun to watch
about him play the boats not gonna drop
it on Robins mmm
all right Olson on the board with the
plop and that's got to be a little
confidence booster okay too far that
time finishes at this side yep given the
bell you check paper balls on Mashpee
push towards a woman it's dawn let's
have rhythm and all socks movement right
now keeping ash truly off base he's
trying to get she's trying to lock him
down with that dirt those down for one
to get in the jab range we can
accomplish we poke with the chap blow to
the fly it's definitely a nice thing
about Bob she also has always had really
good jab right in one thing that's gonna
make the stiff extremely Tom gets the
Walton here reset no didn't quite get
the back - I'll say it's my turn now
hold this wall press do it again the
Gildan work last round we'll try it
again
run it back gets it to spend the rage
she throws away and that just once in a
while support yeah beautiful off to the
wave - there get the whilst and for now
we have a final round situation old sod
who's 414 added up here
or encounter hit good choice go alone
there beat the power crush but look at
all thought taking control down Arthur
Nash tells it with blocker here at the
wild 82 for hash this might be to start
he needed sidewalk rolling with him just
want the whole disposition god that was
so sick old luck getting the burnt game
running it back three rounds straight yo
that crowd - but that's basically an
electric get a back edge there and then
boom off the whip that was sick and that
kind of response in that kind of
situation - that's what you expect them
all sound right then we talked about
strength so much good intuition good
reactions especially in situations like
that that I think would be hard to make
that call for a lot of people he can see
that I'm like I'm like my mind is blown
right now because ulsan just wanna game
up arson with Bob he's getting smoked
here Bob's gonna lose he's got a made me
switch to kazoom he's gotta think about
that run the mirror match but not he's
Bob's like I got this what's it be fair
I think this year was protecting Ward's
war Bob representation I think to this
point outside of all signs but maybe
like 1/2 up a little bit it's pretty
much just been also mm-hmm here we go
game to last day on earth you really
watch you can see in his eye
yeah it's something that always
surprises me back toward what I always
like to see what him its focus mm-hmm
and he read that also was gonna jab
there random but ducked in his face
instant while standing punish out of it
those beautiful the sweet push to the
wall
punished from are slim ash here
and olds I mean I think he's hoping that
arts is a little rattled right from
losing that first game don't from both
the health shoes and put them on till
now working out arsons a lot punished
again arson and rage takes the flash
bone stock down now I see but even some
in that time this is sick
back and forth yo that was tight wall
care here with the chapatis not quite an
old son not content to just car but this
back so while he's swinging trying to
get his way out of there yeah and you
have a very smart there you know block
comes down with just page it they
recognize the wall was close enough to
the back that he would have got walls
flat now for one chop it away all day oh
I'm ready for the holes I play this
character oh that was such a crazy
attempt I like it
low vary from old on wall nice to lay
low wake up he went to the high that
time scare the duck course to the walls
behind them and finish in the strings
old song on the board here ties it up
one apiece
step head lows starting the Hat up now
and he fixes it up to it's just free
push toward the wall and these two jabs
tell sweeps coming he's fortunate look
at the jab sucks pressure right now he
has a read on our savannas timing dude
he punish the jab with his jab from
downtown him now in his set point for
all our son a so here he go
float combo off about 34 by any means
yet he'll know
japchae punish things just tags him low
after it stopped there and then go back
and forth both just guarding content
guard an arson he's got good position
air put oh hold on is not gonna bite
that for that never he's not gonna let
him happen
he's never child that dappled one walk
left every single time I think I'm the
block imma take whatever I mean person
rage vote for old side now candy pulls
out some way flash would come will last
pixels great kick no go final round game
- that was the first time that arson -
boat after flash was knocked out that he
made that he made the right play to be
able to take advantage also an all song
for the most part is that really really
good defense oh yeah crazy
no siree just chopping away chopping
before you know we wanted it so bad well
you had the board three this is a crazy
jab Aldi the rage the bolt addiction Jam
is so good final round to drink those
slowly at that point for old sod
rage mode now available aren't than
trying to close out and get on the board
here the cool he's ready for it Arthur
that's gonna spend the rage art and it's
gonna connect hard without tying it up
one game of peach oh my god
that was Ted we know we talked about the
game differentials potentially mattering
getting that one game there is critical
oh my god Mac the character select and
pulls on what's he gonna do is he gonna
be sticking down with Bob here the
poppet was doing pretty good no it was
for the mirror match he locks in boy now
ours been taking his time to lock in
don't let it breathe after that kind of
match old man it's just some subtle
differences in timing and just
especially with the jab pressure in the
mid range like that like you said bob
has slightly feels like slightly larger
range than her sellers so it's on hash
to be able to try to lead Olsen's timing
and trying to intercept it when she saw
him doing the last round quite often and
now when you look at this like
tournament set you got to wonder you
know obviously old side now he's had
more time to read and download are some
ashes Kazumi arson hasn't had a game at
all against little Suns kizuite let's
see what happens here the mirror match
Devil's pit perfect place to settle it
right off the bat eking aside arson ash
flying back alive board
jab pressured magic for parole thought
tiger
partnership paper volts on for one check
two Marcin all day and love to the wall
to multiple lows in a row from what's on
here and look at that the local folks
just add it up a thin or so that's gotta
find some answers here while I already
put the low this side that's one
Oh interesting go for oaky with it
running to pressure now we haven't seen
much left I look dumb speak it out now
if you hit magazine time nice blocking
punished on the slide and what a big
lead this time what a jab punishing
fourth three again just mixing up
between the jabs in the lows or we're
punishing like that Oh beautiful
Wow got the four three here at the wall
carry two with the tiger gives the run
to the end no spring kick denied twice
oh my god now mixing of those ones that
run to another one no old fun set point
again infinite stage now magic for old
man hey Arsenal gnashing a bit of
trouble year you mentioned earlier put
old sounds timing has been on point in
the set and now it's ours that looking
for the loan and old son reads it gets
the low Perry and he's been old sock
forcing the issue he's the one going in
to punish yo are so does it victim he's
got a reg right now can t make it come
back here somehow don't punish
holding up my being in hands old son
gonna defeat ours and that two to one
year round robin tournament format
though but that is huge that has to be a
huge confidence booster for him in this
group when you make the call I'm gonna
go in the sectioning I'm gonna go in
this text nude I want you and then you
get him and you win like that yeah I
want that Arthur Nash pool and I'm gonna
beat him with his own care it's much
much of the way executed too right Bob
pick Bob I just need you to give me one
game let me go into this start one we've
caused me and then it with the way he
played it too he set the tempo the whole
time
I said I'm real I'm confident in my
defense right common in my movement also
took the fight day him every time
dashing in while also I'm trying to run
away the whole time it didn't work out
he definitely did his home but you know
when we watch arthur nash play you know
his defense is amazing right like he has
the perfect times back dashes in the low
vlogs and the spaces right so he's
always controlling yeah a big part of it
things actually you know keeping the
spacing said he can act be back this out
and make you wit for all time right but
old son wasn't having anything tonight
in the rangecontrol
oh man but coming up next we got shadow
returning to the stage to go up against
neuroma USA versus Japan we haven't seen
the Roma play today yet yeah well to be
honest man it feels like on big stages
he's been a lot more quiet this year
than what we're used to say him right I
mean last year was I mean he had some of
the some of the highest impact
performances in the past to two years at
second which were right you remember
what to Korea oh yeah please player
winning at Korean masters of it I mean
nobody saw that coming but this year it
felt a little bit more subtle
his performance but gonna be interesting
to see how he goat how he fares against
shadow oh yeah without of that play
while these guys said if we are gonna
take a short break guys don't go
anywhere
second World Tour Finals act and gonna
continue in just a second